Thank You Bradley I got sober because of
this guy and every day has been happier
ever since both you and I thank you
their friendship goes back to that epic
selfie at the 2014 Oscars Bradley even
photobomb Brad at a music festival in
2017 now Cooper presented Pitt with an
award from the National Board of Review
in New York I asked his friends you know
what are some words to describe him and
it was integrity and it was his soul the
turning point for Brad appears to have
been that 2016 infamous airplane
argument involving Angelina and their
son Maddox a source tells us Brad had
been drinking on the flight seven months
later he told GQ he gave up alcohol
because quote I don't want to live that
way anymore my goals in life now are
pretty simple just to be happy stay
healthy and not get into a financial
situation where after new oceans 14 as
for his sober pal Bradley Cooper
[Music]
he played an alcoholic and a star is
born and quit drinking when he was 29
Bradley said his low point came when he
quote was at a party and deliberately
bashed my head on the concrete floor I
would never be sitting here with you no
way no chance because because I wouldn't
have been able to have access to myself
or other people or even being able to
take in other people if I hadn't changed
my life no way
[Music]